good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone is having
a wonderful week we are you smell that
we're so
close to friday yeah i'm i'm
i'm feeling good about the rest of the
week like optimistic really
downhill from here we are belatedly
celebrating hump day because t-h-e-o is
in the building
he chose to sit with his auntie just for
a little bit i know he's going to leave
me soon
but it means so much to me that he is up
here right now like
it's been a while i don't know if you
guys like pay attention to
who he sits with but he's really been
choosing you over me like every single
day
well i think he knows that mama's tired
because i was up
all night consuming so much television
oh my god you don't even know
three hours of the cma awards premiere
of real housewives of salt lake city and
then a very subpar
below average mediocre episode of real
housewives of orange county
five hours i watched watch what happens
live because the cast of salt lake city
was on
and it hindered my so i heard it was
wild
and i was so tired you didn't really
miss that much but i just wanted to see
how they like
interact on watch what happens live
because you know it's like when the
it's they're not pretending like they're
just being and in salt lake city like
they're in charge but like at watch drop
inside like andy's in china and i really
just
it didn't change my opinion on anyone i
just um actually maybe a little bit on
lisa like we'll discuss
okay we will discuss because who the
[ __ ] is lisa
um but no last night i was up until 12
30 watching tv and i hadn't even started
orange county and i had to watch orange
county this morning also
so weird i go to turn on the cmas last
night at 8 p.m
and i can't get it on my youtube tv and
i finally realized on twitter that
youtube tv was down for like oh that's
unacceptable
40 minutes from eight to eight forty so
it's like prime tv watching time that i
got backed up on
but and i wasn't planning on watching
the whole cmas me neither
but they started i was captivated and
they were such
a pleasure to watch it was a real award
show
it was a breath of fresh air it was a
real award show like
they were there were people there it
obviously wasn't like a packed stadium
or arena like it usually is
it was like a dinner party for i would
say about 50 people but
not only was it a real award show but
they don't waste time like the cma
awards they go from award to performance
commercial award performance like i feel
like other award shows there's so much
wasted time with like people trying to
make jokes and monologues and all these
like
pre-packaged like packages and i just i
did not plan on watching the whole thing
either but it was
truly captivating it was just i it was
the first
normal feeling thing that i've watched
in a very long time and i was like not
only
am i enjoying this but i want to
encourage this like they found a way
to have everyone in the room we got
celebrity actions and really because no
one's booked and busy
everyone showed up everywhere except for
casey musgraves but everybody who was
nominated in the big categories was
there and like it was just a
star-studded affair
and the performances were on point and i
was really just
thoroughly enjoying myself so i was like
i'm not gonna stop here to go watch
oseed then come back during commercial
like
i was like i'm going to enjoy this well
i definitely wasn't going to leave the
cmas which i was really enjoying for the
real housewives of orange county because
it was just like
in general a trash franchise and last
night was in particular like a really
bad episode
so i did leave a little bit to go watch
salt lake city because i
was really excited about just the
prospect of a new city a new franchise
for housewives
and it really did not disappoint i'm not
disappointed i have many thoughts on
that and orange county which we will be
recapping in our tv recap segment as
usual
yes but it was just um it was a busy
night for us pop culture folk
and tonight is not different we have
kardashians and uh
southern charm yeah it's not terrible
but it's just a lot no but
that i can manage but we had three hours
of cmas two
of five and then watch what happens i've
so five and a half hours of television
five hours and 45 minutes because the
real houses of salt lake city was an
hour and 15 minutes
i didn't even notice that it was extra
long because i was just enjoying every
minute it was an
extra 15 minutes long um also yesterday
i did something
so fun i did a peloton class
with the pella toasters we did a six
o'clock one of the new beyonce rides
that we were talking about
and synergy i rode with 25 east coast
pelatons we were all on the leaderboard
together
and honestly like we were all in the
group after like talking about how we i
didn't pr but a lot of people
did because like we're competing with
each other and like someone like goes
ahead of you and then you want to get
back
and was really motivating and really fun
so if you
like the toast and you like to peloton
head over to the pella toasters facebook
group because
they do these group rides all the time
yeah well i don't have a peloton so i
guess i'll just have
i guess i'll just have to sit in bed all
day always come over and use mine
no actually sorry i sit on the couch all
day i've got to start changing my
birthday
i was on the couch until 12 30 last
night oh wow
oh well so i only got home at like six
o'clock yesterday because i was
recording my audiobook which was
honestly i'm not gonna lie
when before i left here yesterday i was
like really dreading it because it just
sounds like boring
but my god i had so much fun the five
hours just flew by and my book is so
funny you guys preorder now girl with no
job.com
book or tap the link in my bio on my
instagram i have all the links now for
canadian retailers
um but it really would mean a lot to me
if you guys could pre-order it it just
like makes a difference like if i'm
trying to get into bookstores like i'm
just
my goal is to get to the airport like i
feel like you have made it when your
book is sold at the airport
so um in order to get there i just need
lots of pre-sales so
amazon barnes and noble indie bookstores
it's been a tough time
for your local bookstore so maybe go in
there and ask if they can order it for
you
oh that's a nice idea um but yes it was
very fun like i i didn't know what kind
of vibe i wanted to go for and i was
really nervous in the beginning so i'm
actually going to re-do
the introduction because i was sounding
like a freak like just trying to be like
all like presidential but then i
realized i'm like i need to lean into
this like i need to
talk like my normal self but my god
every 10 seconds they would like buzz me
and be like you gotta slow down
and it was just really hard but i have
to go back two more times and it was
really fun
that is really fun and also oh yesterday
i posted podcast episode with dana
yes i heard the reviews are in i was
listening to some of it
some of it and it's just so funny like i
actually i never make you listen to like
should i do without you
but i i i think you should listen to it
you know when the last time you said
that was
what the first patreon with dana and i
did listen to it on a plane
wow yeah so here we go again um
i feel like we have a lot to cover we
have cmas to recap i think like we have
so much tv to recap i think we should
not dilly dally not dilly dally i do
think we should dive
right into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and jackie can you just remind me what
day it is it
is thursday okay wait before i dive into
my little skit
um in my book in the intro there's a use
of
remiss devastated and heartbroken and um
i was reading the sentence and they kept
making me redo it and
and i had to explain to them i'm like no
i'm saying it weird on purpose like
it's it's a podcast thing and they were
like why are you pronouncing rumors
devastated and heartbroken so weirdly
i'm like
i really don't have time to explain it
but just like let me do my thing yeah
and like
so offensive that they didn't listen to
your podcast i know also
are you able to like ad lib at all while
you're reading your book
so i asked before if i was like the
publisher if i was allowed to because
like you know that's so me right like to
throw in a laugh a parenthesis
like laugh yes okay but like hardcore
like me doing stand up
no no but like if you wrote something in
the book but then you have like an
additional thought about it yeah so i
did that twice yesterday
um they said like don't push it because
it really needs to remain true to the
script
like the text but um i talk a lot about
writing my book like the process of it
and just like
i break down the fourth wall like the
fact that i'm talking and writing in a
book and in an audiobook you're not
supposed to do that because it's not a
book it's an
audio book so it's like very confusing
having to like change a few things but
for the most part they really recommend
that you
stick to the the text of the book but
you know that's hard for me
i don't know i just feel like that's so
fun like there are like like little
treats in an audiobook that you can't
get from the text
oh no and like in my um book like i
reference a few songs that just like
made me the woman i am
first you're gonna sing them and i'm i
literally walk in and i'm like she's
like do you have any questions i'm like
no but like i'm allowed to sing right
and she's like no
but mariah carey sings on her audio
they're her own songs
so it's a copyright infringement i have
this secondhand serenade lyric that just
really molded me as a woman
you should reach out to second hand
serenade because i feel like you know
how hard it was for me to say the lyric
instead of like
what is it tonight will be the night
that i will fall for you over again
and there's a whole story about it
really shape me as a woman tonight will
be the night that i will fall for you
over again don't make
me in the like 57th grade just like with
my black eyeliner like that song with my
life
if i had to like guess the one song
lyric that you're going to fight for in
your book
i would have never guessed it'd be that
one well it's the one that shaped me
most as a woman and if you want to know
why
you'll have to read my book coming out
january 26 2021 i guess i have to read
it again
yeah um but i do yeah so that was
really really upsetting for me that like
i could not belt that is upsetting i
literally said i'm like but mariah carey
did it she was like yeah they're her
songs
um but sorry i was asking you do you
know what day it is it is
thursday which means that today's
episode is of course brought to you by
thursday boots
just in time for the start of boot
season we have received a few of the new
releases
from our friends at thursday boots
thursday boots is the new york
city-based startup
that designs really really comfortable
high-quality boots
and sells them at the best
direct-to-consumer prices
they handcraft their boots in the same
north american and european facilities
as brands that charge
two to four times the price but by
cutting out the retail markups they
offer the highest quality boots at very
accessible price points
my favorite over the knee boots that
i've been wearing for like the last year
or uh from last season's thursday boots
and we just got a few of the new ones
from this season and they just like they
know what's up they know the style
they're all i can say i have very low
tolerance for like
heels but all the boots that i have from
thursday boots are incredibly
comfortable totally the type of heels
that you can wear all day the boots are
really just like
the perfect staple basic shoe that is
going to carry you through
season to season great quality great
styles if there ever was a year to
invest in more comfortable
in more comfortable shoes it's now if
you want fast fashion or shoes that
rarely make it out of your closet
do not shop at thursday boots thursday
boots is an investment in comfort
timeless style and staples that will
last for years you deserve
you deserve more comfortable boots
without the high retail markups because
thursday boots is all about
year-round honest pricing at the lowest
sustainable market possible
they never have sales or discounts but
they're giving our listeners free
two-day shipping on their first order
and they always offer free returns and
exchanges so you have nothing
to lose by trying out your first pair go
to thursdayboots.com
toast and you can have a pair on your
doorstep before next thursday
that's t-h-u-r-s-d-a-y-b-o-o-t-s
dot com slash toast for free two-day
shipping plus free returns and exchanges
check it out tell them the morning toast
sent ya sign on
get sickening boots okay first up
country music took center stage at last
night's 2020
cma awards longtime cma's mc carrie
underwood passed the baton
to reba and darius rucker who teamed up
to co-host the live ceremony for music
city center in nashville
tennessee the cma awards honored and
showcased the biggest names in country
music
as well as emerging talent dominating
the country music airwaves
so i'm gonna go through all of the
categories and share the winners then
we'll talk about our favorite
performances how does that sound it
sounds great i just want to say like it
was
it was so good and i want everyone to
know that they all did a good job like
reba darius were amazing the producers
were amazing like the whole show was
amazing
please keep doing it like i feel like we
went from having no award shows having
virtual award shows to now having like
small
having no audience and now we have like
the audiences the stars which is really
all we need like yeah
i didn't need one more thing than what i
got and i just like want the
country music association and everyone
who was a part of that he's going to
sell
a big round of applause to know that
like we appreciated it so much and it
was literally the highlight of my week
and i wasn't expecting it i wasn't even
going to watch the whole thing i was
just going to watch
until how size of orange county started
100 and then i couldn't take my eyes off
of it it was just brilliant performances
everyone gave it their all people in
country music are so
talented musically like they don't have
any like backup dancers like it's just
so real and it was so good
no like i didn't think we could become
bigger country music fans but like last
night just solidified like everything
that i love
about country music and and i will stand
forever
me too and you know what it really made
me realize it's like not only do i like
love music and country music it's like i
think if i had to
ever choose like between watching the
grammys or the cmas like
i would want to watch the cmas totally
and i think if i ever had the
opportunity to go to like the biggest
pop music festival or the biggest kind
of like to be backstage at one of them
sipping out of red cups i would want to
be at the cma's 100
like and that's what i realized last
night like i've always been into country
in addition to everything else
but i think in the last like two years
like my love of country has
and i'm only now realizing it has become
like my main interest in music
yes i only listen to country music yeah
i agree okay so entertainer of the year
which is the big prize
went to eric church yeah so
here's the thing i have a lot of respect
and i understand eric church i'm not a
big follower
but i get i get it um
i did feel like it was luke comes his
ear and of course everyone's just going
to say claudia you're saying that
because you're obsessed with him and his
wife
and while that may be true i do think it
was his year well he did win
album of the year luke combs what you
see is what you get and
vocalist of the year so how do you win
those against eric church
but somehow he was the entertainer of
the year but if your vocals and your
album
technically were better well i just want
to say our church has won entertainer of
the year before right
many times and luke holmes has never won
it and i think one day he will win it
and if i were him i wouldn't want to win
it for the first time in 2020 because
like
it doesn't mean as much there wasn't as
much to entertain yeah no when it's like
and when eric church won lou comes was
so happy for him and i also think it's
like
he didn't want to win this year yeah you
know and he still went home with two
awards so like
let him have his big award like on a
year where he's touring and he is the
entertainer of the year
not just like on this throwaway of a
year that's fine and fair
but okay single of the year
the bones marron morris and she also won
song of the year for that song and i
believe she also won female vocalist of
the year yes
now the bones was first of all marin
mars's most recent album is
so stellar like and it's it's for
everyone yeah even if you don't like
country music
my friends don't like country music and
they love girls if i can just suggest
some songs a song for everything and all
my favorite people do which is with one
of the brothers from brothers osborne
who
i just think he's so hot um her album is
so good and i kind of forget because it
was a little bit like a long time ago
but
in terms of this year but the bones like
really took over like
pop and country so she was sweeping all
these awards and i'm like oh right like
the bones was like such a big song like
my friends who don't know country knew
it and even she performed it last night
too and i was listening to it and like
the lyrics are so beautiful and for me
it really resonates because i always
sing
when the bunk is good the counts don't
matter
and i feel like that's so true like when
you have a good bunk that counts don't
matter and also when the counts is good
the bunk don't matter because then
you're just hanging
with your counselor all day for sure and
so that's why i
really love that song no i totally agree
vocal group of the year went to old
dominion
so happy for them and it would have been
a disgrace if they went to anyone else
um only because like old dominion has
released literally
10 amazing songs at back to back in the
last year and
they had an amazing year and you just
can't deny it but sadly rascal flatts
was nominated in that category and
rascal flatts was also supposed to
perform last night but someone in their
band tested positive for kovid
literally the most unlucky band in the
history of country music
was supposed to go they broke up network
up they were tired supposed to go on
their farewell farewell tour last summer
coveted hit now finally they get to come
back perform at the cmas
someone gets covered so they're just
like it's not their year
yeah i know i didn't know that i know i
didn't know they were supposed to
perform
i did it on there i didn't know that
something was taken from me i know i'm
so sorry to be the one to tell you
oh my god in like while we're filming i
don't have time to like deal with this
no i know
i have to just move on very upsetting
and so like of course i wanted them to
win because they really did release an
amazing album
but old dominion was so like clearly the
winner for sure
i just want to say justice for lady a i
know um
they put out an album this year that is
so stunningly beautiful i feel like they
don't really win a lot of awards anymore
i feel like when they first came on the
scene like they swept
and now they're just like in the
background charles kelly did perform
last night but
i don't know why this last album didn't
get a lot of play i do also feel like
because of all the controversy with
their name
yeah like they're just like no one wants
i know talk about that let's talk about
charles kelly
yeah the performance he gave with um
carly pars i love that song i hope
you're happy now written by lou combs
because lee bryce
tested positive for covet i saw it
yesterday i think he was supposed to
perform
with her of course with her and then
last minute she had to find someone else
in his register
oh i thought it was weird that it was
him i'm pretty sure cause i saw
yesterday morning that he
wasn't going to be at the cmas because
of covid and then charles kelly sang so
i was like okay these two things make
sense
um so then that makes sense that it was
a last minute performance because
charles kelly like
he is always like incredible and he was
just like not doing a good job on the
stage
and i'm like are you okay and then i
realized now i realize it's probably
because he got
one day's notice and he never heard of
this song before yeah okay
then vocal duo of the year was dan and
shay of course there are so many great
country vocal duos like florida george
line maddie and tay
brothers osborne brooks and dunn but i
feel like dan and shea can win any year
they
are they do great things for country
music in general like they brought
justin bieber to the cma they are the
publicists for country music like
they go out into the world and they do
amazing collaborations with tory kelly
justin bieber and
they they do a good job but it really
comes back around to scooter braun
always because he manages them and like
he manages justin and he
he makes those things happen and i
thought that performance was beautiful
like the three-part harmony and honestly
justin bieber looked like so
hot and handsome and i never really
think he's cute but his harmonies were
just like speaking to my soul and i
thought they all did a great job that
was a really good performance
also i don't know if our husbands have
been hanging out but this morning my
husband was singing
they haven't been hanging out and i was
just like what i'm so
lonely okay now let's talk about
performances oh also
those are the awards no because oh here
sorry
musical event of the year went to i hope
you're happy now carly parse and lee
bryce music video of the year went to
bluebird by miranda lambert i'm glad she
finally won something because she was
nominated for everything everything
didn't win
and that song bluebird is
just spectacular that's beautiful i have
to once again and i've said it a few
times already like i do have to
apologize for sleeping
not only sleeping so hard on miranda
lumber but like actually not liking her
and thinking she was like messy no and
like
coming for her she was a little messy in
my defense like she did give me some
material to work with
but i take it all back and she's such a
queen and that song bluebird is so good
and they kept on showing clips for the
music video where she's like in a case
in a cage
in blue feathers and i thought it was
really beautiful so i'm glad that she
won for that
and the new artist of the year a very
competitive category the nominees were
jimmy allen
ingrid andres gabby barrett carly parse
and the winner
morgan wallin honestly any of them could
have won i would have been so happy but
like
as and like morgan wallin's number one
fan
it feels like i'm so happy for him it
was so funny that they made a joke about
quarantining he finally performed more
than my hometown and stopped performing
whiskey glasses
and it was just a beautiful sight to
behold so i'm just i'm always confused
about the cma new
artist of the year category because you
could be
nominated multiple times carly parks was
nominated last year too morgan wallin
has been nominated before
and lauren atkins thomas rhett's wife
presented and she said my husband has
been nominated in this category twice
so yeah i guess you can be nominated
until you win
yeah i guess but i agree i could have
made an argument that any of them
deserved to win and i am just like
since two days ago like so in love with
jimmy allen
and he's so handsome and i didn't
realize that the song he performed that
that was his song like i've heard it on
the radio
he is a p john nation and the whole
tribute to charlie pride was
so cute and charlie pride being so
nervous like i don't know why i like
watching him like made me want to cry
like he was just like a
true old man p john and it was just
precious precious i was also thinking
about jimmy allen i feel like if
we were living in a normal world right
now like he would have been performing
that song on the bachelor this season
yes and then that's like you know what i
mean i feel like it was just like a
super bachelory song that's a really
really good call so i feel like he was
robbed of that opportunity i also feel
like it could have been jordan davis
slow dance in a parking lot oh
yeah i feel like he might have already
played that while this is in a parking
lot um
so i have recently become obsessed with
that song
and i think i already told this story i
texted my friend jordan
yes you told me but i don't think you
talked about so my friend jordan is like
always wanting to know like good country
music so i'm sending him music all the
time
and i've been obsessed with jordan davis
slow dance in a parking lot
and my friend's name was jordan davis
and i
sent him this song i'm like do you sing
this song and he was like oh my god i've
been listening to the song and spotify
so much i didn't realize but that's
why i wanted to tell the story i want to
tell the story because i've become
obsessed with him and
somebody messaged me and they were like
oh my god you love that jordan davis
song i don't know if you know
you guys interviewed him at the cma red
carpet i'm unfamiliar but you stubbed
him
i so of course i had to go back and see
the atrocity that we committed this was
last year
so what had happened what had happened
was it was
the beginning so it's like kind of slow
we were just like talking to anyone and
he came over and he was eating candy
and like two minutes into his interview
carly parks came over so
you know the red carpets are cut throat
and at the time
i didn't know who jordan davis was and
carly parks was nominated for an artist
of the year and it was just like a lot
going on
so we literally just like turned our
backs on him
but we gave him two minutes were we nice
like what did we say
we said what's your name
he said what's your name okay but i just
want an apology to enjoy
you gotta start somewhere 100 and i just
now i'm obsessed with them but i agree
jimmy allen is a great call for someone
who could have performed on the bachelor
and his performance was amazing luke
holmes performed his new song called as
you which was
sensational sensational we had like nico
in the front row being a fan girl
so supportive it was like the closest we
got to a concert like i felt like i was
watching a concert
morgan wallin was excellent i just love
him so much yes
i thought the opening was really
interesting like not what i would have
expected and i didn't recognize darks
long-haired dark it wasn't until in the
middle of the show when he came back to
present something and his name was there
again
that i saw was darks no you know who he
is he's locks
bentley he also performed with the the
other
the osborne brothers brothers osbourne
the brothers oz born who always there's
the one who doesn't look like
the other one no so there was like a um
a trend in country music with duos where
it's like one of the duos does all the
vocals
and then the other guy does everything
else dan and shay
shay sings dan literally does everything
else he writes a song he writes music
florida georgia line tyler hubbard sings
mostly and brian kelly writes
all the songs i can't believe his name
is brian kelly same with maddie and tay
um brothers osborne it's like a trend
but it really works very well but
it's like they you compliment one
another it's like you and i you do all
the vocals i do
do all the phone calls and you do all
the story picking what other
performances
don't in the world full of hate be like
beautiful
reba was just literally performing 400
times like she killed it there's someone
that we need to call out we've spoken
about her
a little bit on the show before but last
night was really her debut ingrid
andres yes performing um
more hearts than mine which is such a
beautiful song
an amazing song like it makes me so
emotional even though like i don't
relate to
any of it you know yeah i i did have a
problem with the crying i'm sorry
i just want to know why she was crying
me too i i hope everything's okay i hope
everything's okay too
but maybe she was just like excited and
overwhelmed in tears of joy
yeah i just i don't know it didn't
strike me
as i didn't mind it i didn't like it it
was a little like that song is really
emotional like maybe she has her heart
broken right now and she's crying
and darius rucker is just like a
wonderful host him and reba did a great
job
i did like them better than past hosts i
think they're like funny and old
and that's like a good combination what
do you think about gabby barrett's
performance
i thought her and charlie pooth were
excellent gabby barrett is very talented
like vocally
also i realized when i got here i'm
wearing my pants inside out but whatever
um gabby barrett is very talented and
charlie puth like really is a wonderful
musician
and and he like added great harmonies i
thought that was a great pairing i loved
that
mm-hmm oh and her husband was on guitar
and she's just like a supportive wife
yeah i love i love that song i love her
and i'm glad that you're coming around
yeah i don't think was i ever like not
around i feel like you've been hard on
her
well i just think like when we've
interviewed her on the red carpet like
she never wants to talk to us so it's
like okay
we're not for everyone that's so true
jackie you know any other standout
performances that you wanted to discuss
before we move on who did we miss kelsey
ballerini performed
yes in the bottle and i finally realized
while i was watching her
also because she had a middle part she
was giving me look-alike vibes
of and i feel like you need to watch the
performance again in order to see it
but it was someone who was actually
asking for us to share
our look like with her tanya rad
okay i definitely see that yeah there
were like certain angles last night and
i was like oh my god i was getting major
tanya wrap
especially with the middle part and so i
was glad i was able to button that one
up interesting
you know what what i felt was
interesting maybe a shift in last
night's um
cma awards i feel like for so long like
every award was being like given to and
nominated to like
jason aldean blake shelton and luke
bryan and honestly like the three of
them were not there
and i kind of liked that i feel like
they're great
but they're not the best country music
has to offer and i feel like forever it
was like literally
the luke jason blake show yeah but it
was jason aldean singing devil went down
to georgia right yes he was excellent he
was excellent and that fiddler oh
you know what we got to get him on the
roof the fiddler was everything of the
sort and when reba said give it up for
brothers osmo
and she didn't even mention the fiddler
maybe the fiddler is part of one of
their bands
of course but still yeah you stole a
show yeah that was a great
little fiddle we got it was an amazing
fiddler moment yeah we love a fiddler
we do put them on the roof particularly
on the roof
now with that i think that is our
official cma recap it was an amazing
show thank you to everyone
who made it happen for us it was really
wonderful it was bruno's first time
watching a country award show and he was
just really catching a vibe
i mean i literally caught the biggest
five out i was just not expecting to
get so much like serotonin from this
award show like it was just making me
happy no i just thought i was like gonna
do my job and watch it and talk about it
and instead like i got so much out of it
100 okay next story switching gears
nikki bella says her ex john cena called
her after the birth of their of her
child
not their child something about like
their entire relationship just like
gives me a pit
really yeah i just don't think that it's
no i just it makes me mad because if i
ever really sit down and think about it
i'm like mad at what he did to her i
know but nikki bella told us weekly this
week that
john and i will be tied forever all i've
ever wanted was for him to be happy
she said so with the baby he reached out
to brie and i both we haven't had an
individual conversation in gosh i don't
know how long
but it was very short and sweet that's
sweet yeah i mean
i don't think john cena is a bad guy but
like it just makes me mad for
bree i know nikki and for women like
he just i'm just mad at him like and i'm
not over the breakup and i took it
really hard
yeah i took it really hard too i'm
getting over it and like the more that
they
find like real love and joy and
happiness
i'm able to move on i think i know why i
took it so hard
because if i really think about it nikki
bella
and john cena were perfect for each
other like compatibility wise
looks wise like they were just really
like a perfect pairing
and the fact that like he went out of
his way to like not make it work like
made me mad and wasted so much of her
time
yeah that's what it is yeah i guess but
she wouldn't be where she is now
yeah yeah everything happens for a
reason yada yada yada yada yada but i'm
just upset on her behalf and i think we
should all be
yeah i know i can't believe they still
talk though i feel like that's just like
a function of the fact that they were in
each other's lives for
five years but then like five years from
now like it sometimes and this is how i
used to feel about going to camp
sometimes you need to spend the exact
amount of time like without something as
you spent with it in order to
like undo the time i feel that you know
so in like five years
so after two months at camp i need you
two months at least
you need at least two months at home
after two months at home like you can no
longer be camp sick
got it you know what i mean i feel that
it's like you've been here longer than
you were at camp what are you doing
right i feel that thank you okay
next story wow this one was a stunner
pregnant emma roberts bears her baby
bump
on the cover of cosmo and it was just
beautiful beautiful stunning and smart
beautiful emma roberts is one hot mama
the pregnant star of netflix's holiday
covers cosmo's december 2020 issue with
her baby bump on full display
and a stunning pink set from frankie's
bikinis that i'm sure is
totally sold out by now totally it's not
the only
belly-bearing look that she um is
modeled for the magazine she also posed
with a croquet mallet and a
cream-colored prada crop top
and hot pants and shredded her stuffed
poolside in a black
cup bra and wolford underwear oh i
didn't see those additional photos
i mean this is so fabulous like i just
love that we're celebrating pregnant
women on the covers of magazines which i
feel like hasn't really been done
that much and this is just absolutely
wonderful i'm just like we were just
talking about this with emily ratakowski
and her digital vogue cover oh yeah like
i would love to see a pregnant belly on
the cover of vogue no i think this is so
excellent i think the photo shoot was
like fun and fresh and young and emma
roberts is just like all of those things
and i feel like i'm i didn't really
expect in 2020 for like this to be where
she's at
but i feel like she's just living her
best life
living her best life i'm really happy
for her and i'm i think this is a great
move by cosmo
and it recently there's actually been
some stuff in the news about garrett
hedlund who is my favorite actor and
her boyfriend father of the baby and it
was actually revealed i think
in january he had a dui
yeah so he's been like struggling with
his sobriety and i think he's in a
better place now and i think a baby
definitely does that to you and i don't
know it's just very exciting to be in
that little family
yeah i i like such a talented family too
wait speaking of emma roberts julia
i was just going to say so that makes
julia roberts the baby's great aunt
great oh that sounds like an old woman
yeah wouldn't she be like a granddad
because i've
always wondered that right is like
double you know aunt
and then great aunt doesn't make sense
because it's mother
grandmother great grandmother yeah so i
think she's like
a granddad the granddad the granddad i
love that
last night before the cmas came on i
realized my youtube tv wasn't working
i went to netflix just like put on a
movie for bruno and i and i started to
watch my best friend's wedding which i
realized is a movie i had never seen
i saw it a really long time ago julia
roberts cameron diaz and dermot mulroney
like a hallmark king no it's
hallmark king georgia rule king hello oh
my god totally
and um something else king
was he a murder on the orient express no
oh well anyways
it was so fantastic and i was just
starting to really get into it because i
really love the two of them but i was
really like am i the only one who's
rooting for cameron diaz and dermot
mulroney like julia roberts i know she's
the protagonist but like
i'm she's really being mean i love
cameron yeah so anyways i have to finish
that movie but
i was just treating myself content upper
it's feeling like one but it's
finish it and then let us know i will i
will it was definitely like a movie that
we would have watched for toast movie of
the day yeah
wow toast movie of the day is so long
ago no
those words trigger yeah no they bring
me back to like a really dark lockdown
place
yeah like and don't even say the words
what are the words what was the first
one
the first what ricky gervais invention
of lying
don't say it don't say it okay next
story some
legal news selena's family
at uh salinas family and netflix are
being sued for over 1 million dollars
over a new series about the late
singer's life
so so by the
man who produced the 1997 selena movie
there's a new selena tv series coming to
netflix it's called selena the series
is it dramatized or like a documentary
dramatized oh interesting and i think we
reported some of the casting news a
while back but the
show is set to premiere in december now
mocktuzuma s
parza who produced the 1997 selena movie
about the late singer that starred
jennifer lopez
filed a 1 million lawsuit last week
against her father and sister
abraham and susette quintanilla as well
as the streaming platform claiming that
he owns the rights to her life story but
was shut
out of the new show according to tmz e
news
okay now explain something to me because
i don't really understand like life
rights
okay you own how do you where do you
purchase the rights to someone's life
i don't know like i would think that
this would be the family
right so it's like the dad and the
sister are on board
mm-hmm with this new tv show and i guess
they cut him out of it and he has some
sort of like ownership over her life
rights which
how can you own someone's legacy i have
no idea
i have no idea it just seems so
unfair i mean who knows that he's just
suing and honestly it's like he probably
thinks he's gonna get something out of
this but
really he's just like looking like a
dick garnering so much press for this
show like i had forgotten about it and i
didn't realize it was premiering in
december and now i'm really excited and
honestly
hasn't selena's family been through
enough like now we're suing her totally
really low class yeah so that's the
latest legal news i
don't understand how someone who's not a
family member could own her life rights
and i just am hoping that justice does
its thing
no but i feel like you can definitely
like purchase the life rights like for a
movie
but i don't think that gives you like
ownership over this person's legacy like
in perpetuity for the rest of the
till time is over like that makes no
sense he's suing for damages from an
alleged breach of contract claiming he
developed an idea for a television
treatment of celina's younger years back
in the late 90s but it was never fully
realized
okay so you had an idea 20 years ago and
like actually 30 years ago
and now we're just supposed to like
remember that yeah this guy sounds like
a little bit like a narcissist if you
ask me
yeah no it's like oh goodbye
come to mama come tomorrow we had a
really nice run i got him like way
longer than i thought i would
and with my rls i keep crossing and
uncrossing my legs and disturbing his
piece by the way we haven't heard an
update in your rls um journey
on my yeah my journey um through rls you
know it's been better and i did get the
magnesium pills but i really have been
forgetting to take them like does anyone
else
just like forget to take time for
vitamins no and honestly
it's like a whole thing because if you
take it in the morning before you eat
anything you could get like
nauseous and throw up so then you have
to eat but then by that time like you're
on your way with your day like who is
remembering to take vitamins
yeah but i also think it was like the
first in the beginning i was probably
like low iron or whatever and i think
i'm just like
eating better i don't know i think it
comes and goes it flares up uh by the
way i do think that that as well
seasonal super flarey okay our fifth and
final story is someone who i know you
don't like discussing on this show
but she's talking about a relationship
and spilling a little tea so okay who is
it chloe kardashian
no no you love chloe you know i do i
thought it was gonna be like more trust
in [ __ ]
julianne huff alludes to felix i don't
not like you you don't like her and
brooks
there's there's definitely a thirstiness
a palpable desperation in the brook
sleighs of it all
and i i know better than to update you
with like details of their
relationship but she's alluding to
feeling lost after her high profile
relationship with ryan seacrest
oh and now she's talking about those
times
i mean those were crazy times because
say what you want people have been
saying things about ryan seacrest
forever
but i don't think he's gay i mean and
that's not where she's going with this
at all and she talks about why they
broke up and i'm sorry i just took a
liberty
no and at the time they said they broke
up during due to scheduling conflicts
which we always know isn't true
but during an instagram live
conversation she talked about how living
the high life
with an ex believed to be ryan seacrest
shaped what she wanted out of life in a
career
she said it was 2013 and i had just
gotten out of a relationship that was
very high profile
i was on private planes and yachts and
living in a very very well-off house and
my life was pretty different from where
i grew up
she shared that she didn't feel like she
had earned the luxuries she was enjoying
adding i had just gotten out of that
relationship because i wanted to create
that for myself
because because i kind of felt like i
didn't deserve it
that's interesting i mean sounds like a
dream you know
flying in planes and living in houses
that you didn't pay for but they also
feel like they wrote i feel like ryan
seacrest is kind of like a two-year
relationship kind of guy
yeah he's a little leo like that yeah he
doesn't go for like
all the like models like he does what's
the less obvious choice
yeah but he goes for like hot young
things
yeah who's he dating now like a hot
young thing that yeah
probably didn't like a no-name hot young
thing yeah
let me go it's kind of smart because
nobody people are always talking about
leo being this like
you know bachelor and dating such young
girls and the girls are always super
high profile and famous
and it's pretty smart ryan seagrass
nobody's talking about like him being
you know a bachelor or dating young
girls because we don't know who the hell
they are
shayna taylor is who he sounds familiar
but oh he's his girlfriend she's his
girlfriend of
seven years now oh hmm
that is a long time that is a long time
give it to him julian huff i just would
say i
you know i want to go complaining about
all the private jets you're
flying well she no she was just saying
that she didn't feel like she deserved
it but inspired her to create it for
herself
to get it on her to earn it on her own
um all right oc and salt lake city
tv recap segment brought to you by thera
breath the world's fastest growing oral
health care solution
because it really works we've been
raving about them for the past few weeks
ever since we started working with their
breath i have all the mouthwash flavors
in my house i suffer from a very very
severe case of duty breath and
so does my husband and all the products
from thera breath are focused on your
oral health and specifically
improving your breath strengthening your
teeth they have gum
that is like gum with the sole purpose
of making your breath smell good and
it's such a relief to just carry it
around
we actually have some right here behind
our flowers it's just a fabulous line of
products they have mints
tooth mouthwashes it's just fabulous
um their mouthwash which is probably
their most popular product
focuses on various on various oral
health care issues like fresh breath
bleeding gums gingivitis anti-cavity and
teeth
straightening and improvement also if
you have dry mouth this might be a good
product for you
all of their products are kosher which
is fabulous vegan
and gluten-free and they're all made in
the usa with the most ethically sourced
ingredients
um if you want to check out some of
their products if there's someone in
your life who might need to help in the
breath department or
you yourself need help in the breath
department go to therabreath.com
toast that's t h e r a b r e
a t h dot com slash toast and
use the code a toast a-t-o-s-t
for to save 25 off on your total order
from the website
so the website that you have to use if
you want to get the 25 is
therabreath.com toast and the promo code
is
a toast a-t-o-s-t a-t-a
a-t-o-a-s-t and save 25
on your total order again promo code a
toast
therabreath.com toast their breath
it's like therapy for your breath
beautiful okay
can we get orange county out of the way
no can we start with salt lake city like
i want to give it my like
i don't have everything i literally have
nothing to say about orange county so me
neither like i actually could not
recap it just because it doesn't deserve
our air time if i'm like honestly if i'm
being honest
yeah i'm fine with that let's just start
with solid city see where it takes so
my notes like i was really just trying
to remember everyone's name
and here's where i landed at the end of
the episode
live for jen yeah live for jen shaw live
for her
chalet um a little confused and sort of
trepidatious about like her wealth and
her clothing in her house when her
husband is a football coach like at a
university i don't know how much that
pays
but it just seemed like they might be
living beyond their means my other
favorite
is heather because she's just everything
of the sort she drinks but she's mormon
and
she's like one foot in one foot out i
thought the whole like
religion conversation was just
fascinating i mean i don't know
anything about mormonism except i did
see book of mormon but i don't think
that was really meant to
educate um and i just think like the
whole show being centered around
lds as they call it is really
interesting it's like
a totally new format totally
and also all of the women have such
interesting backgrounds
they all i mean there are a lot of
different religions
in the mix it's not all mormonism and
then we also have like whitney who was
excommunicated from the mormon church so
like does that mean she's no longer a
mormon or she just like can't go to the
church
i'm sure that i think that means she's
no longer a mormon but like she gets to
choose what she wants to
believe believe so i'm sure all of that
will play out on watch what happens live
last night andy said that heather
throughout the season is like extremely
open about her struggles with
certain parts of mormon faith and i
think that that is a very
interesting like element to add to an
already like interesting group of women
so many of the women like they obviously
married well but they also have like
really interesting and successful
sounding businesses and i
every time they were explaining like you
know my husband does this and so we and
then i also do this i was like
wow there's just so much going on i
agree there's so much fodder and i was
really impressed by all of them i'm also
so impressed
that pretty much all of them have very
long-term marriages
yes and i we've gotten used to
real housewives being women who are
single but
all of the women are very in very
committed relationships except heather i
think is the only single one
and i think that that also gives the
show like a lot of meat
yeah um like to me
what what i heard had heard about the
show was that there was a housewife on
there
who was married to her step grandfather
and that's really what i was looking
forward to
when you know getting involved and
what's her name mary mary mary um did
not disappoint she's going to be
like the the hot mess of the season i
mean i don't know what was more shocking
the fact that she married her step
grandfather which is pretty shocking
or the fact that like everyone was
talking about her clothing and the two
times i saw her show up like she
literally looked insane with the yellow
tights and the fringe boots
and then that green dress and she's so
like sutton's track like
i love your dress valentino runway like
so annoying and it's so
ugly like i honestly i could have found
a dress at h m that was cute
no it's like she has very eclectic style
but it's all designer stuff
and i act i like it i really liked her i
think
what oh my god i did not like it oh my
god i liked her i think she's so
interesting i love that she can't help
but say
what she thinks i think not only is it
interesting that she married her step
grandfather
but she's also a pastor like first lady
she doesn't like the word pastor but
when she said first lady i was like oh
so your husband's a pastor but then she
explained that like she does the
pastoring but she calls herself a first
lady
yeah and that is so interesting no she's
very interesting and also but i did not
like her the fact that the central fight
in this episode was about
the fact that she said that someone
smelled like hospital
is one of the funniest things i've ever
heard it's so funny
and i just have to say saying someone
smells like hospital i i know exactly
exactly what smell the smell was in my
nose yes when she said it saying someone
smells like that
is literally so [ __ ] rude like it's
the meanest thing you could say like
it's a
horrible smell it's the smell of death
like that's what it is
it's the smell of rotting flesh yeah no
i know
and like air conditioning but like that
just
is is a new is a new insult
it's so low it's so she didn't even mean
it to be mean she was just stating
matter-of-factly like the fact that she
couldn't even like
not say that right i just think that
she's like so interesting
she's interesting she was just like
bothering me like i she was
like a little too like unapologetic in
the first episode and it's like
jen shaw was saying like you hurt my
feelings just like you she's a pastor
you would think she'd be like oh i'm so
sorry
get over it but she starts cursing and
then that other blonde woman came over
yeah that other blonde woman so this is
what i said was thursday
this is what i think happened are you
ready for my theory of how television
works
they had that footage of jen shaw and
mary getting along from six months ago
yeah
i think that six months ago they filmed
some sort of pilot for salt lake city
yes
they got all these women together and
people were getting along
then i think that blonde woman was maybe
up to be in the cast and she was
starting stuff by repeating that it's
she said it smelled like hospital
totally totally totally six months later
you get married they get the green light
mary's like oh jen and i like we're
getting along but
someone told her what i said right and
so that's why i think that blonde woman
comes in i think when someone invited
her into the conversation she was like
okay it's my time to be on the show no
you're so
mary shut her down was like you're not a
part of this by the way i thought
her husband slash step grandfather would
be much older looking
yeah she looks older than him no they
look like an age-appropriate couple yeah
i'm really looking forward to hearing
more about what happened there also
because
the grandmother said that like if you
want to inherit like the business you
have to marry the step grandfather but
what's the business because is that the
church the church
okay it's like a very i think lucrative
church i also fell down like a small
rabbit hole on her on tick tock
um there's a girl on tic tac the talk of
shame she does like all bravo content
she's everything of the sort
i just sent you one of her videos about
candace oh i didn't watch it yet sorry
you should watch it
um and she's like there's she was
alluding to like there being some like
weird foul play between
you know mary her step grandfather and
like the grandma like kind of alluding
to like
the fact like maybe they killed her so
they could
get married and like take on the church
it was very dark but like it is worth
it's just a crazy story and it and just
it opens you up so like people like
no like conjecture like these are deeply
interesting people 100
you know live lives that
you we will all be like learning from
and i think that that is so
interesting i think it's a subculture it
is and i but also there are so many like
we have meredith who is jewish and she's
a jewish
and i actually thought that her um
reason for leaving mormonism like
her husband was like i'm black and we
were only allowed into the mormon church
in like the 70s like i actually really
respected that decision yeah
and like her thought process like made a
lot of sense yeah a hundred percent
um lisa who we haven't spoken about yet
but she
is mormon born jewish converted
like got proselytized yeah i guess they
like never felt akin to the jewish faith
looking for a different religion is
jewish yeah that's what i said
i immediately did not like her that's
what i wrote down in my notes you know
what i didn't like her on the show but i
liked her watch what happens live
oh okay i'll watch it whitney i just
think it was you know really like strong
coming out episode one getting married
but okay but it was a vow renewal
and i really liked her yes she's she
seems like she's really smart
in her interviews like she's very club
like she knows what's going on
everywhere but
in person she's like kind of quiet and i
like that her and heather are cousins
because like they'll have like their
backs hopefully and i like them but
who's she cousins with heather
oh yeah heather was at the wedding yeah
and it's so interesting that heather and
whitney
have like deep roots to like the origins
of mormonism
their fourth great grandfather was the
bodyguard for
jo joseph smith no i'm learning so much
about mormon like byu the fact that you
have to decide like a court of conduct
yeah no it's just super interesting like
i feel actually like
whenever there's like mormon
representation in media it's like
negative like always like book of mormon
it's like it's not fair
so i'm actually looking forward to like
getting to know i
also thought it was interesting like the
whole premise of being a good mormon is
like perfection like on
every level like perfect family perfect
thought like i thought that was super
interesting and that makes for like a
great
premise of a housewives show because
like nobody's perfect no
i mean of course and also it's like you
can't drink you can't swear you can't
you know if you're going to be perfect
like you're not going to be talking
about someone but i didn't know that you
could like bend the rules like i thought
if you were mormon like you could not
drink but
they're calling it mormon 2.0 lisa calls
that because she's a tequila company
i think so after watching watch what
happens live i liked lisa in the episode
but then i've never heard of her tequila
companies did you i think that no
i think that she is like the thirstiest
one like i think that she's watched
every single real housewives it's like
studying the playbook
and wants to be like yeah i think this
is like her absolute dream come true
i am team jen shaw i'm just worried
about her finances
and team heather i'm also a little
worried about her finances because she's
the only one whose house we didn't see
we yeah we saw her business yeah we saw
mary's house
we saw everyone and here's what i wrote
i jen had an amazing
chalet no like that is the dream house
also
at meredith's birthday party at jen
shaw's house when jen had a cake come
out i totally thought her husband was
gonna be in there did you
oh no oh okay heather we didn't get a
house
meredith house was very meh but heather
said that her ex-husband
is a billionaire and that her business
is worth 20 million dollars
people say things um i feel like we're
gonna have a lian locken moment with
heather like i'm just
i'm really feeling that way meredith i
don't know if you remember house it's
like
very seventies triangle yeah yeah very
meh
lisa has a nice house she had nice views
though yeah but they
live in utah they all have nice views
lisa had a great very nice like
mcmansion like it looked like a real
model home you know it had like all the
columns
whitney we didn't see her house but is
that where she was getting married was
that her house i don't know
it looked like it was close to the
houses next door but i'm not judging and
mary did we see her house yes it looked
actually like um
a house in potomac like uh it was like
brick it wasn't super
utahi okay but it was it was big i think
you would be okay with it but it did
look
like i saw it it did look like it was
next to the neighbors oh [ __ ]
i but i did see porsches i did see range
rovers i saw lots of wealth i saw lots
of nice selling lots of louis vuitton on
gen chat
she wore shops everything she wore a
scarf that just like
changed my life jenn shaw and um
mary both dress very very well another
indicator that heather
might be a lee unlocking situation is
that purse that she showed up
to jen shaw's house in was just a
disgrace also on watch what happens live
andy asked if like
he was playing a game with them and it
was like is wearing a fake
bag like fake designer stuff worse than
having no designer stuff at all
and everyone agreed with that except for
heather okay so i'm telling you i'm i've
i think it's really suspect that we saw
everyone's house except for her
and i think we're gonna have a leanne
locking moment okay but i really liked
heather and also i think that she's the
one who's doing the voiceovers in all
the previews like
in that means that means she's important
yeah i think that she is
like maybe the backbone of the of the
season i liked her and jen shaw
immediately and also i was like kind of
liking lisa because
i didn't see a reason not how about that
can you tell lisa and meredith apart
i can but it takes a minute i can
everyone's name i like need to pause and
then
um but we have a meredith and a mary
yeah it's so hard to learn these women's
names but yes but
we're doing it and i didn't like that
lisa
was like being weird about heather it's
one thing to not remember someone from
college fine but then like
to not remember them but then like say
that she's like flash or titties like
what no and like in mormonism and also
like that's like she either did that or
she didn't like there's no
in between right also it's just a little
midriff
no it was it was rude like she's
definitely mercy but i thought it was
interesting i think they said this about
her or meredith i can't tell them apart
but like if you want to go to a party at
sundance like lisa that's you have to
know lisa
i forgot that sundance is in utah yeah
it was just very very interesting
i never would have chosen utah for the
next
like city but i think it's an excellent
choice an excellent choice and the way
that it's even being filmed and
the new um soundtrack or the church
the it's so good
so good it's like in beverly hills you
have like dude like
and i was just loving the whole vibe
that they curated
over there i think it's it's gonna be
excellent the taglines were very
meh but it's season one i will give a
and i just
i think that they found a great group of
women with already established
relationships
deeply interesting people on so many
different levels and i really am
i'm all in me too no i think it's very
good i'm very much looking forward to
the rest of the season
speaking of things i'm not looking
forward to real housewives of orange
county like i honestly don't even want
to recap but like i don't even know what
i would say
honestly the only part worth recapping
is bronwyn um helping her son get ready
for drag because that is so
inspiring and she's such a good mom and
her husband too like they didn't make it
weird at all like they made him feel so
comfortable and like
to put that on tv was so brave and to be
that open with him i just thought it was
so amazing and that was literally the
only part of the episode that like was
even remotely interesting like worth
mentioning i don't even know what else
they're setting a great example you know
what i did another thing
was gina giving a victim statement
i didn't even realize that like he could
potentially go to jail yeah
and he'll just i feel like
well we'll see what she decides to do
but there's just so much going on like
in her personal life like it's just so
layered she also like still can't drive
yeah i forgot and also we said last week
that
you know if i were gene i'd be annoyed
the bronze moon is making me go to aaa
like i would have skipped that part but
gene actually has to go
and gina had right gina had offered i
didn't know that yeah and it's like
court ordered that she go so i think
that is actually a perfect activity for
them to do together
the only um super interesting part was
elizabeth
verse shannon no one she oh yes that was
interesting
and i'm good glad like i think that
shannon has been at like the top of the
group
doesn't have to impress everyone for
like years now and good someone is gonna
you know give her a taste of her own
medicine i agree but that was really
funny well gina was like it's literally
like oc
housewife versus oc house like who's the
richest [ __ ] yeah but they were being
like very
you know obvious very carol and luanne
like one uppy
yes but when elizabeth was saying how
she loves her
nieces and they like fulfill her
maternal instinct and i was like she's
just an
sneaky chest all the way like yeah we
love we love a loving aunt but she said
that she
set up one million dollar trust funds
for them but she hasn't told them yet
because she doesn't want them to murder
her but i was on tv no i know but
i thought that was hysterical i actually
really like her except i did come to the
conclusion last night
and you know i'm very focused on the
material things i do think her beach
house
is her only house no because they keep
saying elizabeth's beach house but does
she go anywhere else
give her a chance i think it's her house
and it's still nice i'm just saying
she's coming i i think that she has
another home
i feel like she does i feel like she
said that i don't
okay we'll see i mean but even if it's
her only house like it's
the nicest beach house that we have yeah
right now but it's like actually
beachfront but no no but it's also
no because i think emily's house is
nicer no um
emily lives in the nicest house out of
anyone yes but like
it's not on the beach next to the
neighbors and it's not on the beach and
it's like in a
suburb it's like what you described
it's big but it's a big mansion it's how
you describe it just someone from utah
yeah yeah yeah
um but like one of the kids went pulled
up and they're like where are we oh yeah
we're in lagoona
um other than that like i genuinely have
nothing to say like
nothing happened i can't believe we're
not even at the vow renewal yet no i
know
i'm sure they're like building up to it
it was fine i like the the season's fine
but that was just like a filler
episode yeah but it was fine because we
had like a really busy night tv so i
couldn't have like taken on too much
more no i i really couldn't like i'm
truly overwhelmed
um but that's it anything else you want
to say add jump in recap
no tomorrow's friday so exciting and
we'll see you then for the party
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places
however you listen to podcasts find us
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
we hope you have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow for our final
episode of the week
for friday friday gotta get down on
[Music]
friday